bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica, meu nome é John Matus e sou o diretor técnico de educação na IBM
Quantum. Esta é a 12ª aula da série e é a última aula da terceira unidade, que trata da formulação geral
da informação quântica. Esta aula é centrada em uma noção fundamental em informação quântica, que é a de uma
purificação de um Estado Quântico. Uma purificação de um Estado Quântico representado por alguma Matriz de densidade é um
estado puro de um sistema composto maior que nos deixa com o estado original quando o restante do sistema composto é
descartado ou traçado. Toda Matriz de densidade tem uma purificação e podemos aprender muito
sobre Estados Quânticos e sobre informação quântica em geral estudando purificações. Em um nível intuitivo,
vetores de Estado Quântico que representam estados puros são objetos matemáticos mais simples do que matrizes de densidade, e ao pensar sobre
purificações de estados, conseguimos ver estados quânticos arbitrários de sistemas como sendo apenas partes de algo maior, mas
mais simples. Vamos também falar sobre a Fidelidade entre dois estados quânticos, que é um valor que quantifica a
similaridade ou sobreposição entre eles, e é frequentemente usada como uma forma de medir quão bom um determinado estado é em comparação com
algum estado ideal. Em particular, vamos discutir a definição de fidelidade junto com algumas de suas propriedades básicas, e vamos ver
como a Fidelidade se conecta com purificações. Aqui está uma visão geral da aula: vamos começar com purificações, incluindo a
definição e uma prova simples de sua existência, que nos diz como encontrar uma se precisarmos. Depois vamos discutir algo conhecido
como a decomposição de Schmid de um Vetor de Estado Quântico de dois sistemas, e vamos ver como as decomposições de Schmid se relacionam com
purificações. Em seguida, vamos discutir uma relação criticamente importante entre quaisquer duas purificações do mesmo estado, conhecida como a
equivalência unitária de purificações, e por fim vamos ver alguns exemplos. Depois passamos para a Fidelidade,
incluindo sua definição e algumas de suas propriedades básicas. Vamos falar sobre o Lema da medição suave, que é um fato muito
útil que conecta a Fidelidade de volta às medições, e por fim, para concluir a aula, vamos abordar o teorema de Uhlmann, que
estabelece uma conexão fundamental entre Fidelidade e purificações. Vamos começar com a
definição de uma purificação. Uma purificação de um estado que assumimos ser representado por uma
Matriz de densidade é um estado puro de um sistema composto maior que deixa o estado original com que começamos quando o restante
do sistema composto é traçado. Podemos expressar isso de forma mais precisa em termos matemáticos da seguinte
forma: se temos um sistema X em algum Estado rho, ou seja, rho é uma Matriz de densidade que representa um estado de X,
e S é um Vetor de Estado Quântico de um par de sistemas XY tal que traçar y do estado puro C lado bro mais I
nos deixa com rho, então dizemos que s é uma purificação de rho. Naturalmente, os nomes não importam —
podemos nomear nossos sistemas e estados como quisermos, e a ordem dos sistemas também não importa. Por exemplo,
se o sistema y estivesse à esquerda em vez de à direita, mas todo o resto fosse igual, ainda nos referiríamos a SAI como sendo uma purificação de rho. Mas vamos
manter principalmente essa configuração pelo resto da aula, por questão de simplicidade. E a primeira coisa a dizer
sobre a definição é que purificações sempre existem para toda Matriz de densidade rho. Para ser mais preciso, toda
Matriz de densidade rho tem uma purificação como a definição descreve, desde que o sistema y seja pelo menos tão grande quanto X, o que
quer dizer que y tem pelo menos tantos estados clássicos quanto X. A noção de purificação e o
fato de que purificações sempre existem é criticamente importante, e é também parte do que torna a informação quântica bela, e espero
conseguir te convencer disso até o final da aula. Agora vamos provar que toda Matriz de densidade tem uma purificação, e no
processo veremos como podemos obter uma purificação quando precisarmos. Assim como tínhamos na definição
de purificação, vamos supor que X é um sistema e rho é uma Matriz de densidade que representa um estado de
X. Agora considere qualquer expressão de rho como uma combinação convexa de estados puros, como escrevemos na tela. Em palavras,
para alguma escolha de um inteiro positivo n, temos um vetor de probabilidade p 0 até pN menos 1, bem como vetores de
Estado Quântico 5 0 até 5 n menos um, e ao fazer a média dos estados puros correspondentes ponderados pelas probabilidades,
obtemos rho. Por exemplo, poderíamos usar o teorema espectral para obter uma expressão de rho assim, e se fizéssemos isso,
poderíamos tomar n como sendo o número de estados clássicos de X. Na verdade, poderíamos tomar n como sendo o rank de rho, que é
igual ao número de autovalores não nulos de rho, contando cada um um número de vezes igual à sua multiplicidade, e
isso nunca é maior do que o número de estados clássicos de X, mas pode ser menor. Por outro lado, isso não
precisa ser uma decomposição espectral de rho, e não precisamos que esses Vetores de Estado Quântico sejam ortogonais. Por exemplo, qualquer expressão de rho assim
está ótima. E aqui está uma purificação de rho: a soma percorre os mesmos valores que
na nossa expressão de rho, e dentro da soma tomamos as raízes quadradas das probabilidades multiplicadas a F A tensor com
k a. Aqui, a propósito, estamos assumindo que 0 até n menos um são estados clássicos do segundo sistema y, então
faz sentido que s seja um Vetor de Estado Quântico do par XY como na definição. Na verdade não é importante
aqui que usemos estados da base padrão de Y nessa expressão — você poderia substituir qualquer coleção ortonormal de
estados no lugar de K 0 até Kat n menos um se quisesse. E agora podemos verificar que isso é de fato
uma purificação calculando o Traço parcial sobre y. Aqui está uma expressão do estado que obtemos ao realizar o traço parcial:
o traço de k a bra B é 1 ou 0 dependendo se a é ou não igual a B, então a expressão
simplifica para nossa expressão original de rho, e é simples assim. Então é muito fácil obter uma
purificação, desde que tenhamos estados clássicos suficientes de Y, ou alternativamente um conjunto ortonormal grande o suficiente para usar no
lugar dos estados da base padrão cat 0 até cat n menos um. E a propósito, se o número de
estados clássicos de Y for menor que o rank de rho, então não haverá purificação — deixo isso para você
refletir se quiser. Aqui está um exemplo: vamos considerar
a Matriz de densidade que vimos várias vezes na aula sobre matrizes de densidade. Aqui temos uma expressão dessa
Matriz de densidade como uma combinação convexa de estados puros. Não é uma decomposição espectral, mas não
nos importamos com isso, e com quase nenhum esforço podemos escrever uma purificação do estado seguindo a
receita. Essa não é a única purificação dessa Matriz de densidade — purificações não são únicas — mas tudo bem. A
definição não diz nada sobre unicidade, e na verdade há uma relação muito interessante entre diferentes purificações do mesmo estado, mas
vamos discutir isso um pouco mais tarde na aula. A seguir, vamos considerar as decomposições de Schmid, que são expressões de
vetores de estado quântico bipartites em uma certa forma que vou descrever em instantes. Elas têm o nome de Erhard
Schmidt, o mesmo Schmid conhecido pelo procedimento de ortogonalização de Gram-Schmid, mas no caso das decomposições de Schmid elas provavelmente não deveriam
ter o nome de Schmidt — é matematicamente equivalente a algo chamado decomposição em valores singulares de matrizes, que foi
redescoberta várias vezes, mas isso acontece às vezes. De qualquer forma, é o que queremos dizer
quando nos referimos a uma decomposição de Schmid: para qualquer escolha de um Vetor de Estado Quântico s de um par de
sistemas XY, é sempre possível escrever s em uma forma especial. Essa forma é como
temos aqui na tela, onde R é algum inteiro positivo, p 0 até p R menos um são números reais positivos que
juntos formam um vetor de probabilidade, x0 até xR menos 1 são vetores unitários correspondentes ao sistema X, e y0
até y R menos 1 são vetores unitários correspondentes ao sistema y. Isso pode não parecer particularmente
especial até eu te dizer que ambos os conjuntos x0 até xR menos um e y0 até y R menos um precisam ser
ortonormais. Então por que isso é especial? Bem, se escolhêssemos qualquer base para uma das duas bases — digamos,
os vetores X correspondentes ao sistema X — poderíamos sempre expressar s nessa forma, o que nos forçaria a
selecionar os vetores Y de uma maneira particular. Na verdade, fazemos isso com bastante frequência, como fazemos com uma base padrão quando estamos
nos preparando para analisar uma medição de base padrão. Mas em geral, mesmo que escolhamos uma base ortonormal para os vetores X,
os vetores Y que obtemos não são necessariamente ortonormais. Da mesma forma, se você escolhesse uma
base ortonormal para os vetores Y e tentasse expressar s nessa forma, poderia, mas novamente os vetores X não seriam
necessariamente ortonormais. E por fim, se você escolhesse vetores ortonormais para ambos os sistemas e
tentasse expressar s em uma forma assim, não funcionaria necessariamente, porque você pode precisar de alguns termos cruzados — mas há apenas um
índice nessa soma, que é a, então a forma é especial. Mas é sempre possível
escrever um vetor unitário s assim, e veja como fazer isso: primeiro calcule uma decomposição espectral
para o estado reduzido de qualquer um dos dois sistemas — não importa qual. Mas para descrever como isso é feito, vamos olhar para o estado reduzido de
X, ou seja, estamos traçando y. Isso significa que p 0 até p R menos um são auto-
valores desse estado reduzido rho, e x0 até xR menos um são autovetores unitários correspondentes a esses autovalores. E
a propósito, o entendimento aqui é que estamos ignorando os termos para os quais os autovalores são zero, porque esses termos não contribuem nada para a
soma. Ou seja, p 0 até p R menos um são todos números reais positivos, e R é o número de autovalores não nulos
contando multiplicidades, que é igual ao rank de rho. Isso nos dá p 0 até p R
menos um, bem como x0 até xR menos um. Só falta encontrar os vetores y0 até y R menos
um. Só existe uma escolha que pode possivelmente funcionar — esses vetores são unicamente determinados nesse ponto e podem
ser facilmente encontrados usando a fórmula simples mostrada na tela. E o que é incrível aqui é que
se definirmos esses vetores dessa forma, eles são garantidamente ortonormais — e isso nos dá uma decomposição de Schmid. Não vou argumentar isso neste
vídeo, mas não é muito difícil, e você pode consultar o material escrito da aula se tiver interesse. Verifique
a descrição do vídeo para encontrar o link, como de costume. Como exemplo, vamos considerar este
Vetor de Estado Quântico que obtivemos como purificação do exemplo de Matriz de densidade que continuamos revisitando.
Não é uma decomposição de Schmid porque os estados zero e mais não são ortonormais, mas podemos encontrar uma
usando o procedimento que acabei de descrever. O primeiro passo é calcular uma decomposição espectral para o estado redu-
zido de X, que é esse mesmo exemplo de Matriz de densidade, e aqui está uma decomposição espectral I dele que vimos de volta
na aula 9. Então escolhemos p 0, P1, x0 e X1 como é
mostrado na tela. p 0 e P1 são os autovalores de rho, e x0 e X1 são
autovetores unitários correspondentes. Então resta calcular y0 e y1, e ao fazer isso obtemos cat Mais
para y0 e menos 1 * Kat menos para y1. Isso não é imediato — você precisa
realmente fazer o cálculo para ver — mas é o que obtemos. E como esperado, esses dois vetores são ortonormais como
sempre serão se você fez os cálculos corretamente, e isso nos dá uma decomposição de
Schmid. Decomposições de Schmid são muito úteis em muitas situações, e em breve vamos ver o que elas nos dizem
sobre purificações. Purificações não são únicas — um dado Estado Quântico representado
por uma Matriz de densidade terá, na verdade, infinitas purificações. Há, no entanto, uma
relação estreita que sempre vale entre quaisquer duas purificações do mesmo estado, e às vezes é chamada de
equivalência unitária de purificações. Veja como funciona: seja rho uma Matriz de densidade
representando um estado quântico de um sistema X, e suponha que temos quaisquer duas purificações desse estado que são
estados puros do mesmo sistema composto. Para ser concreto, vamos supor que s e fi
são vetores de estado quântico de um par de sistemas XY que ambos nos dão rho quando o sistema Y é traçado.
O que a equivalência unitária de purificações diz é que deve existir uma operação unitária U que age apenas no
sistema y e que transforma SII em fi. Em outras palavras, embora sejam
purificações arbitrárias de rho, e não assumamos nada sobre elas, exceto que ambas purificam rho e são
ambas estados do mesmo sistema composto XY, elas precisam ser equivalentes em algum sentido, a menos de uma operação unitária em y
sozinho. Vamos ver alguns exemplos que ilustram por que isso é interessante e quais implicações tem, mas primeiro vamos
ver por que é verdade. Vamos começar com uma decomposição espectral de rho, que é a
Matriz de densidade que tanto SII quanto fi purificam. E assim como fizemos ao discutir a decomposição de Schmid, vamos
assumir que descartamos todos os termos correspondentes a autovalores zero. Então p 0 até p R menos 1
são todos números reais positivos, x0 até xR menos um são autovetores ortonormais de rho, e R é o
rank de rho. E a propósito, apenas como observação: perceba com que frequência recorremos ao teorema espectral nesse ponto —
é uma ferramenta incrivelmente útil, e na verdade estaríamos perdidos sem ela. De qualquer forma, agora que temos uma
decomposição espectral de rho, podemos calcular decomposições de Schmid dos nossos dois vetores, assim como antes, e elas vão ser
quase exatamente iguais. Os coeficientes e os vetores X são os mesmos porque vêm da decomposição espectral do estado reduzido, que
é o mesmo para ambos os vetores. A única diferença é que podemos obter vetores diferentes para o segundo sistema. Para
o primeiro vetor, que é s, obteremos um conjunto de vetores y0 até y R menos um, e para o segundo vetor, que é f, obteremos uma
coleção possivelmente diferente, que podemos chamar de z0 até zR menos um. Portanto, agora temos decomposições de Schmid
para os nossos dois vetores que se parecem muito, exceto que os vetores para o segundo sistema podem ser diferentes. Mas essas
são decomposições de Schmid, então essas duas coleções são ambas ortonormais, e podemos simplesmente escolher
uma Matriz unitária U que leva ya a Za para cada a. Você sempre pode fazer isso — operações
unitárias são de fato equivalentes a mapas lineares que transformam uma base ortonormal em outra. E se
esses dois conjuntos não abrangerem todo o espaço correspondente a Y, podemos sempre estendê-los para bases ortonormais
usando, coincidentemente, o procedimento de ortogonalização de Gram-Schmid. E é assim que se prova a
equivalência unitária de purificações. Na aula quatro da série, discutimos o protocolo de codificação superdensa,
que permite a um remetente transmitir dois bits clássicos a um receptor enviando um qubit, ao custo de um ebit de
entrelaçamento compartilhado. Estou assumindo que você já conhece esse protocolo, e o ponto deste exemplo é
explicar brevemente como ele se conecta à equivalência unitária de purificações. Lembre que a forma como
o protocolo funciona é que Alice e Bob compartilham um ebit, ou seja, um Estado de Bell fi mais. Alice escolhe transformar esse
Estado de Bell em qualquer um dos quatro Estados de Bell dependendo dos dois bits que quer enviar, e então ela envia seu
qubit a Bob, que mede para ver qual Estado de Bell tem. Note que todos os quatro estados de Bell
nos dão o mesmo estado reduzido para o qubit de Bob, que é o estado completamente misturado, e na verdade isso já é suficiente
para concluir que a codificação superdensa é possível. Todos os quatro estados de Bell purificam o estado completamente misturado, então pela
equivalência unitária de purificações, sabemos que deve ser possível para Alice transformar o Estado de Bell fi mais em qualquer
um dos outros aplicando alguma operação unitária ao seu qubit. É claro que não é difícil encontrar operações unitárias que
realmente funcionem, e elas são muito simples, mas é interessante que podemos chegar à conclusão de que isso é
possível sem nem pensar nas operações unitárias em si. E além disso, podemos concluir
que generalizações da codificação superdensa para sistemas maiores são possíveis, desde que tenhamos alguma forma de generalizar os estados de Bell para sistemas maiores
de forma que todos eles deem o estado completamente misturado como estado reduzido de Bob — e há de fato diferentes formas conhecidas de fazer
isso. Um contexto diferente no qual a equivalência unitária de purificações tem implicações é a
criptografia quântica, e uma de suas implicações mais importantes é que ela descarta a existência de um protocolo quântico incondicionalmente seguro para uma
primitiva criptográfica conhecida como comprometimento de bit. Então o que é comprometimento de bit? É um exemplo
de uma primitiva criptográfica, ou seja, uma tarefa ou procedimento de baixo nível que fornece alguma funcionalidade básica, que
pode ser usada como bloco de construção para coisas mais interessantes, como criar esquemas de assinatura digital ou construir
protocolos de conhecimento zero. No caso do comprometimento de bit, a funcionalidade básica é que um
jogador, Alice, pode se comprometer com um valor binário de sua escolha a um segundo jogador, Bob, mas a escolha dela permanece oculta
até que ela decida revelá-la. Exigimos duas propriedades específicas de um protocolo que implementa o comprometimento de
bit: ele deve ser vinculante, o que significa que Alice não pode mudar de ideia depois de se comprometer com um bit, e
deve ser ocultante, o que significa que Bob não pode determinar o bit de Alice até que ela decida revelá-
lo. Seria muito legal poder implementar essa primitiva usando informação quântica, porque é uma
primitiva útil — mas sem suposições adicionais, acaba sendo impossível fazê-lo perfeitamente com informação quântica, ou mesmo de forma próxima
ao perfeito. E a equivalência unitária de purificações revela isso. A ideia em alto nível é
que se existisse um protocolo quântico para comprometimento de bit, haveria necessariamente uma versão purificada desse protocolo, onde podemos imaginar que
Alice tem um sistema a, Bob tem um sistema B, e após o comprometimento ser feito, mas antes de Alice revelar, o par AB está em
um de dois estados puros, psi zero ou psi um, dependendo do bit que Alice
se compromete. Se o protocolo for perfeitamente ocultante, então Bob não pode distinguir entre as
duas opções de comprometimento, ou seja, o estado reduzido dele deve ser o mesmo para as duas possibilidades. Porém, isso implica, pela
equivalência unitária de purificações, que Alice pode transformar qualquer um no outro aplicando alguma operação unitária
a a sozinha. Então o protocolo falhou completamente em ser vinculante. Há detalhes que
omiti, mas a essência do problema é que a equivalência unitária de purificações nos diz que essa primitiva não é algo
que podemos implementar de forma confiável usando informação quântica sem suposições adicionais de algum
tipo. O último exemplo de implicação da equivalência unitária de purificações é um teorema conhecido como o
teorema de Hughston, Jozsa e Wootters, ou teorema HJW para abreviar. Vamos começar com o enunciado
do teorema em si — esta é uma versão ligeiramente simplificada para evitar algumas tecnicidades e focar nas ideias principais.
Suponha que X e Y são sistemas e F é qualquer Vetor de Estado Quântico representando um estado puro do par
XY. E agora suponha que pensamos no estado reduzido do sistema X sozinho e chegamos a qualquer forma que
escolhermos para expressar esse estado reduzido como uma combinação convexa de estados puros, como mostrado na tela.
Por exemplo, o número capital N nessa expressão — que é o número de estados puros que estamos fazendo a média —
pode ser arbitrariamente grande, possivelmente muito maior do que a dimensão do espaço correspondente a X ou a Y.
E o que o teorema nos diz é que deve existir uma medição no sistema y com N resultados, tal que
o seguinte acontece quando o sistema Y é medido: primeiro, cada resultado da medição
aparece com probabilidade exatamente igual à probabilidade correspondente em nossa expressão do estado reduzido de X como
combinação convexa de estados puros, e segundo, condicionado a obter um resultado particular da medição, o
estado de X se torna o estado puro correspondente da combinação convexa. Então por que isso é
interessante? Bem, significa que para qualquer forma que escolhermos pensar no estado reduzido de X como uma combinação convexa
de estados puros, existe alguma medição de Y que efetivamente torna essa forma de pensar sobre o estado reduzido de x uma
realidade. E o que é notável é que isso é possível mesmo quando o estado f é escolhido primeiro e a combinação convexa
é escolhida depois — desde que seja uma expressão do estado reduzido de X, haverá uma
medição de Y que funciona exatamente assim. Então vamos ver como podemos provar
isso. Começamos com duas expressões diferentes para o reduzido de X, ao qual daremos o nome de rho por
conveniência. Em seguida, introduzimos um novo sistema Z cujos estados clássicos são os possíveis resultados da medição, ou
equivalentemente, os índices em nossa combinação convexa. E agora podemos observar que os dois Vetores de Estado Quântico a seguir,
gamma 0 e Gamma 1, que são ambos vetores de estado para o sistema composto XYZ, são
ambos purificações de rho. E para ficar claro: quando pensamos nesses vetores como purificações de rho, estamos
pensando nos sistemas Y e Z juntos como um único sistema composto que é traçado para deixar
rho. O primeiro vetor, gamma 0, é essencialmente a mesma coisa que o estado puro original fi, exceto que estamos
inicializando o novo sistema Z para o estado zero. É claro que se traçarmos Y e Z ficaremos com rho, então gamma
0 é uma purificação de rho. O segundo vetor, Gamma 1, é basicamente o vetor que obtemos purificando
rho com base na combinação convexa, assim como descrevi anteriormente na aula. Desta vez, o sistema Y está
inicializado — e estou assumindo por simplicidade que zero é um estado clássico de Y — mas você poderia substituir qualquer
estado da base padrão, ou na verdade qualquer estado puro de Y, nessa expressão e não faria nenhuma diferença. Em qualquer caso, traçar Y e
Z novamente nos deixa com rho. Então a conclusão é que essas são ambas purificações de rho, e portanto, pela
equivalência unitária de purificações, existe uma operação unitária U no par YZ que transforma gamma 0 em
Gamma 1. E isso é tudo que precisamos para chegar a uma descrição de uma medição que faz o que o teorema
diz. Uma forma simples de descrevê-la é com um diagrama de circuit como mostrado aqui na tela. Em palavras: começamos com o
estado F, introduzimos Z inicializado para o estado zero, realizamos U e depois medimos o sistema do topo, que é Z, com uma
medição de base padrão. Efetivamente, isso transforma fi em Gamma 1, e
só de olhar a descrição de Gamma 1 podemos ver que isso faz o que o teorema diz: obtemos
cada resultado a com probabilidade PA e, condicionado a obter a, o sistema X fica no estado sa.
E para ficar claro: a própria medição que o teorema implica a existência é implementada por
tudo o que está dentro do retângulo pontilhado na figura. E se você quiser saber como a
medição pode ser descrita como uma coleção de matrizes, aqui está uma expressão delas. Não vou explicar essa parte — não é
realmente importante para o exemplo — mas essa é uma expressão das matrizes de medição, caso você tenha
interesse. A seguir, vamos discutir Fidelidade, que é uma medida de quão similares dois estados quânticos são, ou alternativamente, de quanto
eles se sobrepõem. Vamos começar com a definição, que pode parecer um pouco misteriosa à
primeira vista, mas vamos desvendá-la, e ao final da discussão espero tê-lo convencido de que é
na verdade uma função muito mais agradável do que pode parecer à primeira vista. E aqui está a
definição: a Fidelidade entre duas matrizes de densidade rho e sigma é igual ao traço da raiz quadrada da
raiz quadrada de rho multiplicada por Sigma multiplicada pela raiz quadrada de rho. Vamos
falar sobre isso primeiro — vamos tentar dar sentido à própria definição. Temos três raízes quadradas e
todas se referem à raiz quadrada de uma Matriz positiva semi-definida, que como discutimos na aula anterior é
a única Matriz positiva semi-definida que ao quadrado nos dá a Matriz da qual estamos tirando a raiz quadrada. Como
rho é uma Matriz de densidade, ela precisa ser positiva semi-definida, então podemos tirar a raiz dela. E se pensarmos na raiz de rho multiplicada por
Sigma pela raiz de rho por um momento, vemos que ela também é positiva semi-definida, e em particular podemos escrevê-la como
M conjugado transposto vezes M, com M sendo a raiz quadrada de Sigma multiplicada pela raiz quadrada de rho. Portanto, podemos tirar a raiz
quadrada disso. Em particular, podemos calcular uma decomposição espectral da raiz de
rho vezes Sigma vezes a raiz de rho, e para tirar a raiz quadrada basta tirar a raiz quadrada dos auto-
valores e deixar os autovetores em paz. E por fim tiramos o traço dessa
Matriz. E como o traço é igual à soma dos autovalores, obtemos a expressão que temos aqui
mesmo. Então provavelmente não é algo que você queira calcular à mão em geral, e essa explicação pode não
oferecer muita intuição sobre a Fidelidade ou por que nos importamos com ela, mas esperamos que esclareça o
significado técnico da fórmula. A propósito, às vezes as pessoas definem a Fidelidade como
o quadrado da função que defini aqui, e chamam essa função de raiz de
Fidelidade. Você verá as duas definições, o que certamente tem potencial para causar confusão, mas normalmente não causa
porque as pessoas geralmente são bastante cuidadosas em deixar claro qual definição estão usando, e você
deve fazer o mesmo. Ao meu ver, não existe uma definição certa ou errada. Eu a defino
assim simplesmente porque me acostumei a fazer dessa forma, e acho que é um pouco mais conveniente, acho que prefiro elevar ao
quadrado do que tirar uma raiz quadrada depois quando for necessário. Mas é claro que você é livre para fazer sua própria
escolha. De qualquer forma, voltemos à Fidelidade como definida aqui. Existem outras formas equivalentes de
definir a Fidelidade, e é uma função bastante notável nesse sentido — pode ser caracterizada de formas bem interessantes.
Aqui está uma forma bastante direta de reescrever a definição em termos da Norma de Traço, que vimos no final
da aula anterior. Não entrei em muitos detalhes sobre a norma de traço e, em particular,
não a defini para matrizes não hermitianas, mas ela tem uma definição simples. Uma forma de definir a Norma de Traço de uma
Matriz arbitrária m é que é o traço da raiz quadrada de M vezes M conjugado transposto, ou equivalentemente o traço da raiz
quadrada de M conjugado transposto vezes M — você obtém o mesmo valor de qualquer forma. E podemos usar essa definição para simplificar a
definição da Fidelidade, como está aqui na parte inferior da tela, e isso é legal porque revela que
ela é simétrica nos dois argumentos. Também podemos expressar a Norma de Traço de uma Matriz quadrada M como o
máximo do valor absoluto do traço de M vezes U, variando sobre todas as matrizes unitárias U — o que não é óbvio, mas é
verdade — e isso nos dá outra expressão para a Fidelidade. Então temos três
definições equivalentes para a Fidelidade, e isso é só o começo — há várias outras definições equivalentes,
e vamos ver uma particularmente importante que vem do teorema de Uhlmann no final da aula.
Tudo bem, mas o que isso tudo significa em um nível intuitivo e por que devemos nos importar com essa
função? Para responder a essas perguntas, é útil considerar o caso especial em que pelo menos uma das duas
matrizes de densidade representa um estado puro. Se ambos os estados são puros, então a
Fidelidade é simplesmente o valor absoluto do produto interno entre os dois Vetores de Estado Quântico, e de certa forma
essa é uma motivação principal para a própria Fidelidade. O valor absoluto do produto interno entre dois Vetores de Estado Quântico
é sempre um número entre zero e um, e nos dá uma forma natural de medir o quanto há de sobreposição
entre dois Vetores de Estado Quântico. E você pode pensar na Fidelidade como sendo uma forma útil e bem-comportada de
estender essa forma de medir sobreposição dos estados puros para matrizes de densidade. Se um dos estados é puro
e o outro não necessariamente é puro, então novamente temos uma expressão simples para a Fidelidade, que pode ser bastante
útil, e essa expressão está mostrada aqui. A Fidelidade tem muitas propriedades interessantes,
e é por isso que as pessoas a usam. Ela tem uma definição que não é lá muito elegante, mas é uma função muito útil
mesmo assim, e é frequentemente muito fácil de usar, em parte por causa de suas muitas propriedades
incríveis. Então vamos dar uma olhada em algumas delas. Começando com a observação de que a Fidelidade entre duas
matrizes de densidade é sempre um número entre 0 e 1. É zero se e somente se os estados
são ortogonais, ou seja, as imagens são subespaços ortogonais, ou equivalentemente, que o produto das duas matrizes é
zero. E a Fidelidade é um se e somente se as duas matrizes de densidade são iguais. Todo outro caso está em algum lugar no
meio, mas intuitivamente, quanto mais próxima a Fidelidade estiver de um, mais similares são os estados, ou alternativamente,
mais eles se sobrepõem. A Fidelidade também é simétrica — mencionei isso há alguns momentos. É
bastante claro na expressão que vimos para a Fidelidade em termos da Norma de Traço, mas é uma coisa importante de reconhecer
mesmo assim. A seguir, a Fidelidade é multiplicativa para estados produto, ou seja, a Fidelidade entre dois
estados produto é sempre igual ao produto das fidelidades entre os estados
individuais. Aqui está uma propriedade realmente útil: se temos quaisquer duas matrizes de densidade do mesmo tamanho
junto com qualquer canal que receba essas matrizes de densidade como entrada, a Fidelidade só pode aumentar quando esse canal
é aplicado a ambos os estados. Em outras palavras, em termos de Fidelidade, canais só podem tornar os estados
mais similares entre si — não podem torná-los menos similares. E por fim, para essa lista pelo menos,
há uma relação bastante próxima entre a Fidelidade e a distância de traço entre os estados, que é definida
como metade da Norma de Traço da diferença entre as duas matrizes de densidade. A distância de traço entre dois
estados se conecta fortemente ao quão bem podemos distingui-los, o que discutimos na aula anterior no contexto da
discriminação de estados e do teorema de Helstrom-Holevo. Enquanto a Fidelidade quantifica o quanto dois estados
se sobrepõem. Então embora não sejam exatamente a mesma coisa, não é surpreendente que haja uma relação entre essas
duas quantidades. De qualquer forma, essas desigualdades, normalmente chamadas de desigualdades de Fuchs-van de Graaf, tornam
essa relação matematicamente precisa, e é bastante importante que não há absolutamente nenhuma dependência aqui do tamanho do sistema
do qual estamos falando. Podemos ver essa relação um pouco mais claramente com a ajuda de uma figura: se temos dois estados e
colocamos a distância de traço entre eles no eixo x e a Fidelidade no eixo y, então as
linhas vertical e horizontal correspondentes precisam se cruzar em algum lugar dentro desta região cinza. A região mais interessante
do gráfico, pelo menos na prática, é o canto superior esquerdo da região cinza. Em particular, quando a
distância de traço é muito pequena, a Fidelidade precisa estar muito próxima de um, e vice-
versa. Essas desigualdades são usadas com muita frequência, e parte da razão é que frequentemente nos importamos mais com
a distância de traço no final das contas, porque tem uma interpretação natural conectada à discriminação de estado quântico.
Mas a Fidelidade tem tantas propriedades incríveis que geralmente é a mais fácil de trabalhar. E contanto que estejamos no canto superior esquerdo da
região cinza, que é onde frequentemente nos encontramos, não perdemos muito ao converter entre a Fidelidade e a distância de traço. Então essas
são algumas das propriedades da Fidelidade — há muito mais, mas é um bom começo, e espero que a lista seja
útil para começar a desenvolver alguma intuição sobre a Fidelidade. Aqui está um belo exemplo de como podemos
conectar a Fidelidade a medições não destrutivas. É um fato muito útil conhecido como o Lema da medição
suave. Suponha que temos um sistema x, um estado de X representado por uma Matriz de densidade rho, e uma medição no sistema X
descrita por uma coleção de matrizes positivas semi-definidas. Suponha que um dos resultados da medição tem probabilidade muito alta de
aparecer se realizarmos a medição no estado rho. Por simplicidade, vamos supor
que é o resultado Z Z que é muito provável, e em particular vamos assumir que esse resultado aparece com
probabilidade maior que 1 menos Epsilon para algum valor pequeno de Epsilon que na verdade não precisamos especificar. Epsilon
é apenas algum número real positivo pequeno. Agora descrevemos nossa medição como se fosse destrutiva,
mas sabemos da aula anterior que poderíamos implementar essa medição de forma não destrutiva, e especificamente poderíamos fazer isso como
vimos em nossa discussão do teorema de Neymark: cada resultado a aparece com
probabilidade igual ao traço de PA vezes rho, e condicionado a obter esse resultado, o estado de X muda. Em
particular, no caso de obtermos o resultado provável zero, o estado se torna a raiz quadrada de p 0 vezes rho vezes a raiz quadrada de p 0,
tudo normalizado para obtermos uma Matriz de densidade. E o que o Lema da medição suave nos diz é que nesse evento,
ou seja, quando obtemos de fato o resultado provável da medição, o estado que obtemos não terá mudado muito em relação ao
original, e em particular a Fidelidade ao quadrado será necessariamente maior que 1 menos
Epsilon. E isso é ótimo porque é completamente geral — não dissemos absolutamente nada sobre a medição ou
o estado, exceto que um dos resultados é muito provável. Então o Lema pode ser aplicado em
muitos contextos diferentes onde gostaríamos de verificar algo sobre um Estado Quântico sem perturbá-lo muito. Então vamos ver como podemos
provar isso. Na maior parte, é uma questão bastante simples de calcular a Fidelidade entre os estados pré e pós-medição.
Podemos fazer isso usando a definição original, e normalmente isso poderia nos deixar com uma fórmula complicada, mas
nesse caso temos sorte, porque o que está dentro da raiz quadrada externa é na verdade o quadrado de uma matriz que
acontece ser positiva semi-definida, o que torna o cálculo da raiz quadrada trivial. Agora podemos usar a propriedade cíclica
do traço junto com a linearidade do traço para simplificar nossa expressão, como mostrado na tela. Note que essas são
todas igualdades, então não aproximamos nada até agora — estamos apenas simplificando. Mas agora precisamos de uma
desigualdade porque gostaríamos de eliminar aquela raiz quadrada no numerador. E podemos fazer isso se estivermos dispostos a nos contentar com um limite inferior. Se
você tiver interesse nos detalhes dessa parte, pode obter a desigualdade facilmente considerando uma decomposição espectral de p
0. Os autovalores de p 0 precisam estar entre 0 e 1 — isso é sempre verdade para matrizes que descrevem
medições — e uma vez que sabemos isso, a desigualdade segue diretamente do fato de que tirar a raiz quadrada de
um número entre 0 e 1 só pode torná-lo maior. Outra forma de dizer isso é que elevar ao quadrado um número entre 0 e
1 só pode torná-lo menor. Agora podemos simplificar um pouco mais e obtemos a raiz
quadrada do traço de p 0 vezes rho. Por fim, elevando ambos os lados ao quadrado e
substituindo nosso limite na probabilidade, obtemos o que queríamos. Então a fórmula da Fidelidade
não é a fórmula mais elegante ou fácil de usar do mundo, mas aqui ela funciona muito
bem. Para concluir a aula, vamos dar uma olhada no teorema de Uhlmann, que é um fato fundamental sobre a Fidelidade que
a conecta à noção de purificação. O que o teorema diz em termos simples é que a Fidelidade entre quaisquer dois
estados quânticos é igual ao produto interno máximo em valor absoluto entre duas purificações desses
estados. Com um pouco mais de detalhe: suponha que rho e sigma são matrizes de densidade para algum sistema X, e suponha que Y é um
sistema que tem pelo menos tantos estados clássicos quanto X — portanto, temos a garantia de que ambos os estados têm purificações que são
vetores de estado quântico de XY. Podemos então expressar a implicação do teorema na forma da equação
mostrada na tela: a Fidelidade entre rho e sigma é igual ao valor absoluto máximo do produto interno
entre F e SII, variando sobre todos os fi e S que purificam rho e sigma,
respectivamente. Então vamos organizar isso e trabalhar com o enunciado matemático preciso daqui para frente. O que faremos agora é provar
o teorema, mas primeiro vale a pena um momento para apreciar que ele nos oferece uma forma bastante intuitiva de pensar sobre a
Fidelidade. Também é bastante útil por si só — por exemplo, para provar coisas ainda mais interessantes sobre
a Fidelidade. Para prová-lo, começaremos com decomposições espectrais de nossas
matrizes de densidade — sem surpresas. Uma vez que temos decomposições espectrais, é fácil chegar a
duas purificações específicas desses estados. Mas aqui vamos usar
um truque. Note que em ambos os casos, não temos um vetor da base padrão como segundo fator tensor, como tínhamos anteriormente na
aula, mas sim o mesmo vetor do primeiro fator tensor, exceto que tem uma barra sobre ele, e
isso significa o complexo conjugado entrada a entrada desses vetores. Em outras palavras, estamos basicamente pegando uma
segunda cópia dos autovetores, mas tomando o complexo conjugado de cada entrada, e vamos ver por que fazemos isso em alguns
instantes — não é nada óbvio que devemos fazer isso, e é por isso que chamamos de
truque. De qualquer forma, essas são purificações de rho e sigma respectivamente, o que é verdade em virtude
do fato de que nossos autovetores são ortonormais, e portanto seus complexos conjugados entrada a entrada também são. E agora podemos aplicar a
equivalência unitária de purificações, que diz que toda purificação dos nossos dois estados pode ser obtida
aplicando uma operação unitária ao sistema que é traçado. Para as escolhas específicas de purificações que
acabamos de fazer, as operações unitárias não precisam ser as mesmas para as duas purificações —
é claro. Então aqui usamos a letra U para a primeira e a letra V para a segunda.
O ponto é que toda purificação dos nossos dois estados pode ser escrita como temos na tela para
alguma escolha de operações unitárias U e V. E agora podemos pegar a expressão
do teorema e simplificar. Se substituirmos nossas expressões para F e S e simplificarmos um pouco, obtemos
a expressão mostrada aqui na tela. Há alguns passos aí que não mostrei os detalhes —
você já sabe o que fazer se quiser. Mas deixa eu mencionar que a razão pela qual escolhemos as purificações como escolhemos
foi para permitir que esse produto interno se simplifique exatamente dessa forma. Em particular, colocamos os complexos conjugados
lá para efetivamente conseguir inverter os produtos internos no segundo fator tensor e obter a forma específica
que temos aqui. Quase lá — agora podemos usar a propriedade cíclica do traço junto
com as decomposições espectrais com que começamos para obter essa expressão. E nesse ponto podemos
empregar uma das formas alternativas de expressar a Fidelidade usando a norma de traço, e
pronto. Certamente há detalhes aí que passei por cima muito rapidamente, e é o tipo de prova que você
realmente precisa percorrer por conta própria para entender completamente, mas espero que isso te dê a ideia básica.
E como sempre, você pode encontrar mais detalhes no conteúdo escrito da aula, que está linkado na descrição
do vídeo. E essa é a conclusão da aula, que foi sobre purificações, Fidelidade e as conexões entre elas. É também
o final da unidade, que foi sobre a formulação geral da informação quântica. Espero que você se junte a mim para
a quarta e última unidade da série, que é sobre correção de erros quânticos. Obrigado por assistir!